we are down and windy right now look at
that palm tree boy it's bending in the
wind lots of dark clouds out there we've
got this pacific storm that's blowing
through this morning want to share a
beautiful shot though john salvi stepped
out his door yesterday evening as the
sun was setting and this is the gorgeous
shot that he picked up oh my gosh thank
you for sending that in i love that
buttery sunshine but we're going to see
a lot more clouds than sun if you'd like
to share your photos maybe today of the
weather with this system blowing in
picks pix
8newsnow.com just do that for us please
we're getting a little snow in the
mountains and we're also getting a lot
of wind and we're going to get more dust
in the air today too at least moderate
counts of dust as far as air quality
goes mulberry ash
high counts of those pollens right now
so a lot of folks are really sneezing
and it's all going to swirl around in
the wind today lots of 50s around the
valley and we
had to relax kind of an hour where the
winds relax a little bit but now they're
really picking up again and they're out
of the northwest which is going to make
temperatures feel even cooler today
but they are up a little bit with the
cloud cover we're definitely milder than
yesterday morning as far as numbers go
but it feels chillier with the winds 40s
in brump and indian springs mesquite
moapa valley has had rain and as we look
at this system now on the satellite and
the radar there's there's some cloud
cover but a little bit of rain and we've
had a little snow in the sheep mountains
to the north spring mountains to the
west we weren't looking for a lot of
rain less than 5 hundredths of an inch
up in the moapa valley overnight and now
as we zoom in on the radar the latest
image showing us a little bit of rain
between trump and sandy valley a little
snow in the spring mountains in the
higher elevations although snow levels
could be a little bit lower today with
the cold air that's moving in and some
light sprinkles along i-15 south of town
so we'll keep that chance of showers
through the morning hours and then wind
advisories start at 8 a.m until 6 p.m
for all of southern nevada northwest
arizona and southeast california 30
degrees that's where we are in the
mountains right now temperatures are
only going to get colder through the day
in the mountains 58 for the valley and
again the chance of morning rain and
snow for the mountains and that's really
about it then we'll have some sunshine a
little bit this afternoon and lots of
wind those 40 50 mile an hour winds
today it's just going to rough things up
please be careful and then for the
weekend we get sunshine with 70s as we
spring forward into daylight saving time